well I am never going to look at Britney
Spears the same way again Spring
Breakers is directed by Harmony Korine
and it stars James Franco Selena Gomez
Vanessa Hudgens Ashley Benson and Rachel
Korine this movie tells the tale of four
young girls who want to go on a spring
break vacation in doing so they get
involved with a lot of really rough and
bad people and end up getting in contact
with James Franco who is a rapper slash
arms and drug dealer and through him
they get engaged in a life of crime lots
of partying and lots of spring breaking
spring breakers played at TIFF last year
and I was going to go to it but some
reasons scheduling conflicts gotten away
and I didn't get to see it so I was
interested in seeing this movie because
the filmmaker is really unique he has a
really interesting style that really no
other director right now is using his
films definitely stand out they're not
all good also I like James Franco a lot
as an actor he definitely goes really
far into his performances he gets
totally lost in his performances he does
some seriously outlandish stuff in this
movie and I was interested in seeing
these Disney Channel Princesses get a
little down and dirty and they did
before I tell you how I feel about this
movie let me reiterate a point I've made
in the past whenever a movie features
almost endless partying and drugs and
alcohol and everything and stuff that I
just don't really get involved in that
much it's really important for a movie
like that Ted characters that are
interesting and a story that is
interesting so that I can actually get
involved with it that's why I didn't
like 21 and / or project X because those
movies featured characters that I would
never be friends with but also I didn't
find the movies or the characters
interesting at all and I found the
writing to be really sloppy and the
filmmaking to be poor but I send those
reviews though is that I'm not against
the movie simply because I don't agree
with the things they're doing or because
I wouldn't actually be friends with them
it's all about the filmmaking and I'm
really glad I said that in those reviews
because Spring Breakers is the perfect
example I can use to prove my point
because I enjoyed spring breakers for
what it was and that's because the
characters and the story in the
filmmaking techniques actually made it
interesting although I did feel to the
overall narrative and tonal
inconsistency that kept taking place
took me out of the movie a lot because I
felt that some of the writing was a
little bit sloppy for the dialogue a lot
of times they
use dialogue to literally repeat the
same dialogue multiple times over and
over again it's not just the characters
saying the same thing it's actually in
the movie as let's repeat that exact
same line again and then we'll repeat it
again and then we repeated again and it
got a little weird
it took me out of the movie to be honest
it made me aware of the director at that
point made me aware of it and it was
like what why is he doing this there was
a lot of choices throughout the movie
like that did confuse me but I was
always consistently interested in where
these characters were going to go and I
was entertained for the most part with
this movie largely because of a great
performance by James Franco this guy is
hilarious in this movie and extremely
extremely good as this rapper arms drug
dealer he did a really good job in this
movie also it was kind of cool to see
like Selena Gomez and especially vanessa
Hutchens
go like all out and just completely away
from the whole High School Musical and
Disney Channel stuff none of that is in
this movie for sure there's there's some
yeah there's some things mm-hmm as I
said the tone was sometimes odd and very
inconsistent and there were some editing
choices that I didn't really agree with
and there were some odd dialogue that
didn't seem like it fit in the movie
some of it just felt like yes this is a
movie right now that you're watching you
know what I mean it just felt a little
bit too montage ish there's a lot of
montage stuff with whispered dialogue
very terrence malick ii in a way but
nonetheless I found myself enjoying the
film and wanting to see what happened
with these characters and although the
ending of the film which I will not
spoil I felt was kind of preposterous I
really enjoyed the way that it was done
and I thought that although some of it
seemed a little anticlimactic like
certain things just happened way too
fast I like the way this film was made
it's just something about this movie I
was interested while watching it and
there would be people who say this is
horrible like they will go to this movie
expecting like an American Pie or a
project X or 21 and over and they're
going to actually see some pretty artsy
stuff and a lot of people are going to
hate this movie and I can understand why
but with this movie it just there's
something about it that kind of draws
you in and keeps you in its grasp it's a
little hypnotic actually the music and
everything and I got to say my favorite
scene in this movie is the greatest use
of a Britney Spears song I have ever
heard in the movie and they did a really
good job with it in this movie and
believe it or not it actually fit really
well and I love that scene oh no I'm
going to give Spring Breakers a b-minus
I think that it's a good movie that you
should experience if you are interested
in seeing a very different type of film
when you walked into this movie some
people may have thought it was going to
be something a lot different than what
they got but I think it's different in a
good way
thanks a lot for watching guys and as
always if you liked this you can click
right here and get stuck my noise